what we're going to do in this video is
get a little bit of practice estimating
dividing with decimals so for example we
want to figure out approximately that's
what these kind of squiggly equal sign
means this means approximately equal so
what is 80 divided by 1.9 for
approximately equal so we want to
estimate what this is so pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
so before we even look at these choices
how would we try to do this in our head
well we could say 1.9 4 it's hard to do
that in our head to divide it into 80
but it's awfully close to 2 so we could
say this is close to this is
approximately equal to 80 divided by 2
because once again 1.9 4 is awfully
close to 2 and then this is easy to
figure out that is going to be equal to
40 so our first expression you could say
is approximately equal to 40 is it
exactly equal to 40 no but it's pretty
close so I would select that choice
let's do another one so pause this video
and see if you can figure out the
approximation what is 209 divided by 3
roughly equal to so once again here we
don't have any clear decimals if we were
to divide it out we would get a decimal
answer for our quotient but what we
could do is well it's either one of
these is for example 209 is it close to
a multiple of 3 that we might recognize
well you might immediately recognize
that well if you think about multiples
of 3 you think in terms of well 3 times
6 is 18 3 times 7 is 21 well this is
close to 210 so this is approximately
equal to 210 divided by 3 now why is
this interesting
well 210 is just 21 times 10 so if 21
divided by 3 is 7 210 divided by 3 is
going to be equal to 70 so once again
209 is pretty close to 210 remember
we're just estimating and so 209 divided
by 3 would approximately be equal to 70
which is that choice right over there
let's do one more example so once again
pause the video and figure out what six
point
eight six divided by 1.1 two is
approximately equal to alright so here I
would just try to round to the nearest
whole number and see if that helps my
division in my head so six point eight
six is approximately seven if we round
up to the nearest whole number
and if I say seven divided by and if we
round down one point one two seven
divided by 1 this is much easier for us
to do in our head so that is going to be
seven now once again it's very important
to realize these are estimations it's
not going to be exactly equal to seven
but it's definitely gonna be much closer
to seven than 7,700 or seven thousand